all right so this is a came from the
nightosphere
another Marceline episode we get
Marceline's dad
this was fun this is the first one the
second season and it's I can't forget a
little bit of Marceline's tied to back
story she's angry at her father because
he ate her fries and she wrote a song
about it and Finn thinks he could do
good if he summons him and he does that
and he does that make him like the
vampire Emperor see how she's the
vampire queen
no it's never well what's above Queen in
later episode you'll find out a bit more
of the hierarchy of well guess from okay
uh is he a vampire too you know what
honestly I can't truly say if he is or
not they sometimes say I don't my souls
no no that's the thing it's uh just sort
of its own thing yeah it's way okay so
so he gets mad just decides if he wants
to eat soul so he just goes out and
starts doing that
Gunther apparently is the most evil
thing in the world and nobody knew so he
throws them leading to that I love any
joke I was telling them earlier elevate
joke about how penguins can't fly or
flying penguins any of that stuff I
don't know why it just ain't joking here
about always makes me laugh I love the
one sin sizzle the con that's coming all
the penguins fly away or in the critic
when like there's a penguin flying to
play it's like wait a minute penguins
can fly and I just I love this one Tory
throws him that he's flapping his wings
aces doctor who said you could fly I I
don't know why penguin flying to us
really thinking laughs so but okay so we
got so he's getting bigger and bigger
and eating more and more Souls and at
the end Finn placed the song they kind
of reconcile the father feels really bad
that he ate her fries and then freeze
the souls it sends him back to wherever
he came from some sort of hell another
then the nightosphere that's right I
wonder what the nightosphere is now now
I'm like you'll serious okay that that
sounds like fun
just just you just have to remember
bananas when it comes to the
nightosphere just remember bananas I'm a
banana because he did that one episode
you know that just totally puts but oh
that scene in a totally different
perspective now does it really mm-hmm
now I'm so curious okay I'm definitely
not reading the comments on this but but
yeah but a lot of things down this well
I get it it's mostly at night so I
really like the night colors and this I
mean any time they do night colors which
is funny usually you know everything is
so bright and colorful and think during
the daytime you know whatever the pinks
and yellows and all the various colors
that that would stand out the most but
really is what everything do the
nighttime stuff they just picked these
really nice kinda like it neon turquoise
colors and Stunna then against the dark
blue and they really pop I really liked
the one where they're in the the the red
oh my god like Canyon where he's
crushing the ants I really loved that
color of red it was especially against
the blue yeah really cool and the I love
the design of him when he shows I guess
is true form and every time I saw it it
cracked me up I mean it's just when it's
trying to look scarier it's trying to
talk serious and just that side where
were you know that side always vagina
mouth whatever it just really made me
laugh fortune cookie yes exactly like a
fortune cookie or pinatas yeah when I go
back to that but just as it looks like
something out of the wall
it looks like yeah at the end of the
wall and it looked like that but he had
a normal voice coming out which yeah it
was really funny um and it's just funny
how it's so strange because you just
when you hear them talking so seriously
about you know sort of their torn
relationship but it's just over stinking
fries it's like you're still in it
you're selling oh I hope they you know
turn out okay
and everything like they do seem to have
this connection likely plays the song
and everything but it's I guess in a
sense it doesn't really matter what
they're arguing about maybe that's kind
of the joke or kind of the drama that I
don't know but you just know they had
this falling out and they don't really
want to be that separate I mean they'll
be angrier but they don't want be that
separate and I think by just making it
over something that clearly doesn't
matter but unless they go into like in
the future episodes like maybe the fries
were either the price for a metaphor or
like like the fries were actually like
her brothers and sisters or something I
don't know or like your best friends but
just price
I mean it's and you will see okay said
did it go more into like the whole
Friday kind of yeah I'm really curious
because like I said even even if they
never did it's just serve like bizarrely
the drama in it is like so kind of
engaging so I was just like you know I
don't think I just want them to like be
okay I don't care what the fries are but
it's like I want them to be okay through
it so it it surprisingly it really works
even though it's about something so
silly and stupid when you have a giant
demon thing that's sucking up Souls
starting to cry over something like this
I mean it kind of touches yet it's like
it's kind of nice to know that the only
other thing I can think of is when he
first comes out that they make the whole
room go red because yeah I guess of the
the portal whatever and there's like a
sound effect going out and it's just
screaming or like some sort of
uncomfortable sound effect but just
while he's saying they're just talking
normally but that sound effect is going
there is sort of like this uncomfortable
feeling and I yeah I'll say myself like
you know he's legitimately intimidating
right now anything well was I think it
is that sound in those colors and he's
just so calm with these horrible sounds
going on yeah in a while you know of
course fans terrified the Marceline I
guess it's more annoyed but so what
about the song you know with Finn you
know breaking down having the beat and
everything
I loved him getting more yeah he's doing
the beat it just Lily my I loved him
getting bump I loved because the whole
time I was saying whoa is this like the
first episode without Jake and at the
end it just makes a great joke it's such
a good joke because it turns I says
pocket the whole time and the pocket
throughout the whole episode looks a
little different it looks a little weird
it's just a couple of other lines on
there and that's it so you're not
intentionally you're not actually gonna
verbalize what's up with his pocket but
you've just noticed that enough and then
when she brings it up at the end it's
just that oh yeah Jackie sitting here
it's just obvious like it they couldn't
think of where to put him in the
episodes that's just like oh yeah it
takes her to just to say that he made it
in every episode or whatever so well
actually for me I almost took it as they
almost showed that they can write an
episode focusing around Finn and or
Marceline without having to have Jake
there as like his comedic companion or
the one to get him out of every
situation
it felt more like no this is just a Finn
episode Finn doesn't need Jake all the
time he doesn't always need to be there
because the entire time he's obviously
in his pocket and he never hops up to
help and Finn never asks for help so I
think those kind of a mill Finn can
handle himself this is a Finn episode
yeah it's like because it does get like
it gets pretty extreme I mean it's like
sucking out all the soul that's like
he's like all the guys that do is that
and Finn's go on I mean so yeah it is
kind of interesting you've never like
actually says you know but whatever it
is it's it's really funny oh yeah and
then just a happen turn part in this
base which makes you fail party over
that was pretty funny yeah just that
there's no other saying there's no yes
so uh no I I know it's guy I thought was
a really good episode how but you know
this is actually one of my favorites
especially because of the Gunter scene I
I've always been a fan of him and
everything and just I've already quoted
at least twice during these be logs and
everything so yeah the Crete like
Marceline's dad there's at least two
times where he opens his mouth and
inside his mouth at the back of it is
where he actually starts talking from
you see it's on it's important in the
back and he's talking in the back of his
own throat
is a salad that the thing he turns into
is in the back woopsy it's first off
when he's looking at Finn he's like I'm
gonna suck your soul and in his back of
his throat is this little like face it's
going yeah I'm like very interesting
design I mean initially I never thought
about the show from like the design
aspect I was always like oh this is
pretty neat but every time you say it
it's like yeah you're right the
designers say so good yeah and it takes
so much creativity in such abstract
thinking to come up with these ideas oh
you know how to come up with these looks
so yeah and this one because when it
started out I wasn't a fan of the
designs that much I guess I'd just the
dotted eyes I couldn't get that into and
you know everything else just in what at
the time I was like yeah creative but
just kind of basic won't work whatever
but it's it's really grown on me like
that time and now especially with what
they do with the eyes that they can make
them bigger or smaller give them pupils
or whatever you know they have so much
fun with it I did I really like I drew
really like the design work in this yeah
sticking with it so just get used to the
singing more songs here to come okay
is there more Auto tuning or whatever
that every once in a while yeah whatever
Finn does that that kills me I don't
know why it just really amazed because
it's so spontaneous and out of nowhere
oh and the only other thing I'll say is
that the the Ice King in this I love it
when III think you got you got good
characters when they introduce a new
character and then when you're gonna see
them interact with one you're aware of
you're actually excited and not like
they did a lot with it or anything but
just seeing the Ice King yeah I get all
high hose that guy and then go over
there and just seeing the interaction
it's like I love little scenes like that
I love waiting for those comedic
interactions and it was funny
so yeah so just solid episode hey guys
just watch out for cows with poo brain
so thanks poo with you isn't it yes
puh-puh-puh Oh God poopoo or should we
do that we'll be poopy poopy poopy poopy
definite Malcolm bill yeah okay see you
again I like that show yeah so do I
poopy poopy